25 years ago you played a concert in
front of the entire world
one month ago you played in Barstow
California for 40 people most of them
were there for $2 taco night Bill and Ted
what have you got to say for yourselves
be excellent to each other and party on dudes
You were supposed to unite the world and
save reality as we know it. Bill we spent our
whole life trying to write the song that
we unite the world why can't we just go
to the future when we have written it
whoa take it from ourselves
But isn't that stealing?
how is that stealing if we're stealing
it from ourselves dude
no way how'd you like our song it's a
little on the dark side but you know
that's cool!
Hi I'm Alex Winter. Hi I'm
Keanu Reeves and together we are
wid stallyns
and we know it's a tough time
right now and that you're having to do
this virtual graduation ah we want to
wish you the best of luck moving forward
yeah congratulations to the graduating
class of 2020 well done
san dimas High School football does rule!
Rules!
but most
importantly we wanted to tell you to be
excellent to each other
and party on
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie! Party on.
This is going to be my Bill and Ted a
three trailer video if you guys didn't
know they made a sequel to the Bill &
Ted movies it's Bill and Ted faced the
music so we'll break it down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
an Amazon giveaway I'll explain what's
going on with the release two because
there's no release date in the trailer
but right now it's listed for an August
release so I think they're just trying
to figure out when they're going to drop it
they're bringing back a ton of stuff
from the first two films don't worry if
you haven't seen any of the Bill and Ted
films you just see Keanu Reeves and
you're like what kind of John wick
prequel is this what's going on here
they even did a special graduation video
for San Dimas high school in California
that's the high school that they
attended in the movies so that we're
doing it for the high school in real
life because of the virus right now most
people are having to do virtual online
graduation ceremonies so this is them
just doing something nice for them in
real life but they're a couple moments
in the trailer where they chart the
timeline to explain what's happened so
far and what's going on to create the
problems that they have to solve for
this movie so if you've never seen a
Bill and Ted film its Keanu Reeves and
Alex winter bill S Preston Esquire and
Ted Theodore Logan this is some
old-school Keanu Reeves going back to 89
for the first film in the 1991 for the
second film they even did a TV series
for Bill and Ted they came back into the
voices for the anime
serious for just the first season but I
think they did two seasons of that the
title of the movie is Bill and Ted faced
the music because it's Bill and Ted
facing reality coming to grips with
middle age they're facing the music that
they were supposed to create to unite
the world but haven't done yet and
they're also metaphorically facing the
music as in dying again briefly
seemingly because they brought death
back the character from Bill and Ted's
bogus journey played by William Sadler
he's been in a billion movies and TV
shows usually playing villain characters
so you probably recognize them from
somewhere but the trailer begins with
them in the future again in this utopia
facing the council because they haven't
written the song that's supposed to save
the world yet remember they kept hyping
that up in the first two films he'll
create this wonderful music that creates
this utopia you bring the world together
usually that's George Carlin's character
Rufus that would tell them that but
because he passed away in real life they
said they're not going to recast the
character for this movie so there's no
Rufus in this movie except an archival
footage so there will be some actual
Rufus going on but it's stuff that they
filmed a long time ago the big problem
in this movie because they haven't
created that special music yet is that
the future is threatened the world is
threatened but it's also the universe as
well so they literally have to save the
universe by creating this special music
when this council member says 25 years
ago you played a concert for the world
that's the events of Bill and Ted's
bogus journey the second movie that was
the one where they fought the evil Bill
and Ted robots from the future and also
time traveled so they could spend 16
months getting guitar lessons and
becoming good guitar players because the
whole joke of the first two movies was
if they create this amazing music in the
future but in present day of the 80s in
the early 90s they're terrible musicians
even the princesses that they steal from
medieval England and bring back to
present-day become better musicians than
they do on the fly in the background of
the freeway here in the trailer you
could see people looking like they're
just appearing out of nowhere Terminator
style like they can't control the
timeline as it's breaking down the rules
of time travel in the villains head
universe are not like Avengers endgame
they don't create branch realities when
they change stuff in the past they just
changed their own one timeline past
present and future they recite their
signature catchphrase party on be
excellent to each other we get
our first shot of the signature phone
booth usually another big trope of the
Bill and Ted movies is that they're
given this special time-travel device
the phone booth but they usually use it
wrong and wined up breaking it at some
point during the movies and then have to
fix it so things go completely crazy as
you can see during the trailer as I said
they brought back William Sadler as
death
this is them in Hell visiting him as you
can see the molten fiery landscape
behind them they died briefly during
Bill & Ted's bogus journey the second
film and that's how they met at that
time maybe they also died during this
movie for a hot minute and that's how
they wind up back talking to him again
the reason why they befriend death in
the second film is that in order to make
it back to the world of the living they
had to defeat death in a game of their
choosing
so they challenged him to a game of
Twister and battleship and won so the
death was forced to become their servant
for a little while for some reason
they're super ripped and swole in prison
here with tats and everything these are
probably the versions of themselves that
they run into in the future when they
say that they're going to try and steal the
song from themselves in the future like
something terrible happens to them in
the future and they wind up in prison at
some point they didn't say who the main
villain of the movie is this time but it
feels kind of like the first film where
Ted's father was kind of the antagonist
but not really the villain because he
was threatening to send him to military
school
if he didn't graduate from high school
in order to do that he had to pass the
history exam which is the reason for all
of their time travel in the first film
they kind of imply in this trailer that
they create a lot of these problems for
themselves so they might wind up being
the antagonists of their own film just
by watching time travel and not doing
the things that they're supposed to do
they said in the movie that during the
present day of 2020 when this is all
taking place they are circling the drain
metaphorically both their lives are kind
of falling apart their marriages aren't
doing so hot to the princesses their
daughters hate them would you actually
see during the trailer so not only are
they trying to save the future in the
universe they're also trying to save
their families from falling apart their
lives from falling apart in present day
if you haven't seen the first two Bill
and Ted films Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure and villains Hezbollah's
journey they're cult classics they made
the first film on a budget of six and a
half million dollars so that explains
why they use some of the twists the way
that they do if you're wondering why it
looks the way that it does
so quick rundown of the first two films
if it's been a while since you've seen
them the first movie is them trying to
save the future because Keanu Reeves Ted
character might not pass history and
could get sent to military school and
thus they never become the wild
stallions of the future creating the
special music to bring the world
together creating the Utopia they travel
through history collecting a bunch of
historical figures to do this history
report for them and that's pretty much
it it's a pretty simple plot along the
way they meet two princesses while
they're in medieval England and take
them with them to the Future to become
their wives the whole thing with the
second movie Bill and Ted's bogus
journey is them also saving the future
in a bigger way because an evil ex gym
teacher from the future that's right
evil ex gym teacher hates the peaceful
future that they helped create because
apparently gym teachers do not exist in
the future anymore so he basically took
their jobs
everybody post your South Park memes so
he creates two evil Bill and Ted robots
to go back into the past and ruin their
lives so they lose the Battle of the
Bands referenced during this trailer at
the beginning when she says 25 years ago
you played for the world
the robots wind up killing them during
the film that's how they wind up in Hell
meeting and befriending death and then
they make it back in the way they defeat
the villain at the end of that film is
through a lot of complex time-travel
logic and trickery mostly talking him
into being defeated then because they
still have to win the Battle of the
Bands but they're terrible at guitar
they time-travel with their wives for
sixteen months getting guitar lessons so
that they can get good comeback and
actually win the contest and then the
end credits scene is basically a montage
of their futures and a bunch of
headlines of all the great things that
they were supposed to do and eventually
wind up doing so I'm assuming that this
movie is all taking place before those
headlines I've been watching so much
Keanu Reeves in John wick and thinking
about him in Marvel movies lately that
it's been a while since I've seen him in
a comedy it's been a while since I've
seen those first two films so everyone
just post all your reactions to this
film let me know have you seen the first
two films or is this your very first
Bill and Ted film what will happen is is
it sounds like they're planning on
releasing the movies sometime towards
the end of the summer initially that
might change a little bit just because
everyone's trying to figure out movie
they schedules for the second half of
the year right now the first really
really big movie that's supposed to be
released in theaters is Christopher
Nolan's Tennant in July if that actually
winds up happening then we'll probably
see this movie sometime in August right
now because of the virus and the way
people are lifting the quarantine slowly
movie theaters are just barely starting
to reopen so it's a week-by-week kind of
thing like just play it by ear to see
how things go by the time we get to July
in August there was also some big Batman
and Joker news recently so I'll do a
video for that next that video should
post in a little while while you wait
for everything click here for my brand
new Marvel Eternals first look video and
click here for my brand new spider-man 3
video thank you so much for watching
everyone party on be excellent to each
other I'll see you guys tonight!